hi everyone this is Professor M de
science and today we want to answer the
question what happens after a quantum
measurement this is another one of our
videos on rigorous quantum mechanics
what happens after you measure a
physical property of a particle is one
of the weirdest things in quantum
mechanics to understand it we're going
to focus on a particular example what
happens after you measure the position
of a particle in an infinite square well
using the infinite square well as an
example has the advantage that the mass
is very simple so you can see with your
own eyes where the physics comes from I
have also prepared some animations along
the way so this will be a very visual
and interactive video in fact you will
be able to modify the animations
yourselves and play around with the time
dependence of a particle in a box by
checking my Jupiter notebook linked in
the description also if you haven't seen
the video yet on the basics of the
infinite square well potential check it
out otherwise let's go the dynamics of a
quantum system is governed by the
Schrodinger equation this equation which
features in postulate six of quantum
mechanics plays the same role that
Newton's second law plays in the case of
classical mechanics what I have here is
the one dimensional Schrodinger equation
written in the position representation
when the potential is time independent
then the dynamics of the system takes a
particularly simple form and it is what
I want to explore in this video for full
details about how this works check the
video on the Schrodinger equation what I
will do here is I will summarize the
main results that will allow us to study
I nameks of a specific system to study
the dynamics of the system we have to
start at the beginning what does the
system look like at time equals zero we
write the wave function Phi of X at time
zero as an expansion over the basis
functions psi n of X which in turn are
obtained as the eigenstates of the
Hamiltonian in this context the
eigenvalue equation for the hamiltonian
is sometimes also known as the time
independent Schrodinger equation in it
thus I n of X are the eigen state of the
Hamiltonian and the en or the eigen
values or energy levels associated with
the Hamiltonian these two ingredients
are all we need in order to catch the
dynamics of our system solving the
Schrodinger equation tells us that at a
later time T the wave function psi X of
T is given as again an expansion in
terms of the
sigh n of X and now the expansion
coefficient cn are time dependent and
their time dependence is given by CN T
equals C n 0 e to the minus I en T over
H bar the number of terms that appear in
the sum over n here depends on the
initial conditions and in the special
case when the initial state is an
eigenstate of the hamiltonian that only
a single term appears in this sum in
that case the time dependence becomes
trivial and we call those stationary
states to see why the time dependent is
trivial in this case we consider the
wave function Phi X of T with a single
term J in the expansion and the time
dependents are shown here and we know
that the relevant information about our
system is given by the absolute value
squared of the wave function and when we
calculate that we see that the
exponential term that captures time
dependence goes away the result is that
we end up with a wave function whose
absolute value squared is time
independent and that's why this is
called a stationary state this result
also highlights the fact that
multiplying our wave function by a
global phase does not change the physics
because this global phase always goes
away when we take the absolute value
squared what I want to tell you about in
this video is what happens when there is
more than one term in this sum in that
case the dynamics becomes much more
interesting to do that we only have to
follow the following recipe first we
have to solve the eigenvalue equation
for the hamiltonian to find the energy
eigenstates and energy eigenvalues
second we have to expand the initial
state of our system in the basis form by
the eigen state of the Hamiltonian and
third we have to construct the state of
our system at a later time T simply by
building the time-dependent of the
expansion coefficients by using the
eigenvalues of the hamiltonian the
example i will use in the rest of the
video is that of the infinite square
well potential this is a system that we
can solve analytically and in fact we
have already solved the eigenvalue
equation for this system check out the
video in the description all we have to
do moving forward then is to do point
two and point three here to understand
the dynamics of the system as a reminder
when we solved the eigenvalue equation
for the infinite square well potential
we found that the energy eigen values
were quantized ye of n was proportional
to n square
where n could only take integer values
the Associated wave functions psi n of X
has definite parity because the infinite
square well potential is symmetric with
respect to a reflection about the center
of the well as such they were
proportional to the cosine for all N and
proportional to the sine for even n to
study the dynamics of a quantum system
we're going to start with the simplest
possible extension to stationary States
which is the time evolution of a
superposition of two energy eigenstates
to do that we write our initial wave
function psi x0 as an equal
superposition of website J and psy K in
this case the expansion coefficients e
j0 and c k0 are equal to each other and
equal to 1 over square root of 2 we
choose 1 over square root of 2 to make
sure that the wave function is
normalized the wave function at a later
time T is now simply psi X of T is equal
to 1 over square root of 2 psy J of X e
to the minus i ej T over H bar plus Phi
K of X e to the minus I ek T over H bar
remembering that all we care about is
the absolute value squared of the wave
function we can multiply our wave
function by a global phase e to the i ej
T over H bar and this gives us a very
convenient expression for the wave
function where the time dependence is
only in the decide K term calculating
the absolute value squared of the wave
function now gives us this expression
here which has four terms
the first two terms are time independent
and it is the cross terms that capture
the time dependence if we look at the
wave function psi n of X at the top we
see that it is in fact a real wave
function that means that the stars in
the cross terms are irrelevant this
means that we can combine the cross
terms into a single expression that
depends on a cosine function this cosine
function captures all the time dependent
of our system and the frequency at which
the cosine oscillates is given by the
energy difference between the two eigen
states that are included in the sub this
last term is called the mixing term and
is the one that allows us to have more
interesting dynamics beyond those of the
stationary States to study concrete
example I'm going to look at the case
when J equals one and K equals two the
first term is time independent it
corresponds to the ground state wave
function of our system which we can draw
here and it's absolute value squared is
given by this the second term is again
time independent it corresponds to the
first excited state wave function and
again we can draw its absolute value
squared the third term is the one that's
interesting from a time dependence point
of view if we start with Phi 1 times Phi
2 we just have to multiply the two wave
functions we already drawn and we obtain
this green curve here and then this term
captures the time dependents through the
cosine function which oscillates at
frequency Omega which is equal in this
case to e 2 minus u 1 over H bar to
build the absolute value squared of the
total wave function we need to add these
three terms and we obtain the red curve
here at time equals zero the green curve
will oscillate due to the cosine term
with a period 2pi over omega which in
this case is 2 pi H bar over e to minus
e1 and for example we can ask what
happens at a time we dissolve that
period at that point in time we obtain
cosine of Pi which is minus 1 so the
green curve is multiplied by minus 1 and
we obtain that the total wave function
squared is given by this dashed curve
here we can see that the high peak on
the right hand side of the well has
decreased in size where the small peak
on the left hand side of the well has
increased in size if we consider smooth
changes in time we'll see that the peaks
oscillate at a frequency Omega it is
quite
strucked if to see how this works in
some more detail so I have implemented
the dynamics of the system in a jupiter
notebook and you can find the link in
the description and you can play with it
yourself what i'm showing here are two
examples of the output of that codes and
the one on the Left corresponds to J
equals 1 k equals 2 the case we were
just discussing the frequency of
oscillation Omega is proportional to the
energy difference between the two states
that we are mixing and in this case it
corresponds to the energy difference
between e 2 and E 1 and this is what the
dynamics of the system looks like we see
that the high probability of finding the
particle and either side of the well
oscillates periodically in time the case
on the right corresponds to J equals 1 k
equals 20 the K equals 20 energy level
has many more peaks and this is why the
initial wave function looks like it does
the frequency is still proportional to
the energy difference between the two
states that were mixing and we realize
that the energy difference on the left
hand side is much smaller than the
energy difference on the right hand side
that implies that the frequency of
oscillation will be much larger on the
right hand side than on the left hand
side as we can very clearly see again
have a play yourself with the jupiter
notebook to see what happens when you
mix different energy levels now that we
understand the dynamics of a system that
mixes two energy levels we're ready to
tackle the much more general problem of
what happens when we have a general
mixture of energy levels to do that
we're going to look at the concrete
example of the time evolution of a
system after a position measurement a
position measurement collapses the
wavefunction to a single point in space
where the particle is measured to be we
can therefore write the initial wave
function Phi X 0 as the Delta function
centered on X naught where X naught is
where the particle is measured to be
here I must make a subtle but important
point which is the fact that the Delta
function is not normalizable the Delta
function is not a square integrable wave
function and therefore it doesn't belong
to the hilbert space of valid wave
functions so what does it really mean
when we say that we measure the particle
to be at X naught what we mean is that
the particle is in a very small region
in space centered at X naught we write
the corresponding function as capital
Delta X minus X naught which is a
function that peaks at X naught but it
has a finite width this makes this
function normalizable and therefore it's
a proper wave function in our here
space in this language the delta
function represents a limit of the
capital delta function that we can get
arbitrarily close to but never quite
rich to simplify the maths in what
follows i will in the first instance use
the delta function and then will
construct the capital delta function to
do the proper physics as always we start
by applying the initial conditions so we
write phi x of 0 as an expansion over
the basis functions phi n of x and to
calculate the expansion coefficient CN
of 0 we need to calculate the overlap
between the wave function and the basis
functions remembering that the wave
function is simply the delta function
then the calculation of the integral is
very simple and we obtain sy n of x 0 we
now construct our wave function at a
later time T in the usual manner by
having the time dependent in the
Exponential's and this term here
corresponds to the time dependency NT we
can replace now the expression we found
above for CN 0 and we obtain this
expression here it is important to note
that the PSI n X naught in this case is
a constant because it is the function
evaluated at a specific point X naught
where the PSI n of X here is a function
of X the psi n of X functions are sines
and cosines so how can we combine them
to give us a delta function what's going
on here is that these are precisely the
expansion coefficients that lead to
destructive interference between the
sine and cosine terms absolutely
everywhere in a space apart from the X
naught point where they lead to
constructive interference now that we
have a mathematical expression for psi X
of T we want to understand what this
means physically at the time equals 0
the initial wave function was a delta
function and we can draw a delta
function inside the well however we
remember that this was not a valid wave
function instead we had the capital
delta function which is a function that
still centered on X naught that now has
some width around X naught from a
numerical point of view all we have to
do in the solution above is to truncate
the sum over N to some finite number of
terms and then we obtain an
approximation to the Delta function that
gives us a capital Delta function that
is a properly normalizable wave function
that therefore belongs to our hilbert
space the reason why we obtain a finite
width when we truncate the sum is
because by neglecting some terms we now
no longer have the destructive
interference that we had when we
the pure delta function to understand
what happened at the later time t1 we
note that each basis function Phi of n
oscillate at a different frequency Omega
n equals e and over h-bar because each
basis function oscillates at a different
frequency then this will break further
the destructive interference that led to
the very localized wave function that we
started with and this means that the
overall wave function will spread at
much later times the coherence that we
had at the beginning to localize the
state at a single point will be
completely destroyed and the wave
function will be completely flat and the
particle could be anywhere in the well
to finish I want to show you another
simulation of the dynamics of this
system and again you can play with it
yourself by following the link in the
description what I'm showing here is the
initial wave function centered at X
naught truncate that 100 terms in the
expansion above and you can see that
indeed it is very much localized around
X naught but it still has some finite
width we can therefore write it as Delta
X minus X naught we can now look at the
evolution of a quantum particle right
after a measurement and we can see that
initially this very narrow distribution
starts spreading around that point it
first hits a wall it then hits the other
wall and eventually the distribution
looks completely flat very different to
the one we started with
having seen this it is instructive to
compare the classical case to the
quantum case of measuring a particle and
seeing how it evolves in time afterwards
at time zero when we measure the
particle in the classical case we know
that the particle is exactly at X naught
in the quantum case we know it is around
X naught at later times in the classical
case Newton's laws tell us exactly what
the position of the particle will be in
the quantum case the time evolution is
governed by the Schrodinger equation and
all it tells us is what the wave
function will be at a later time but all
the wave function is telling us is what
is the probability of finding the
particle at any given point when we
measure it again in the example we have
here on the left you can see that the
probability at a later time is pretty
much all over the world so we can draw
this horizontal line telling us that the
probability is essentially uniform
within the well so the particle could be
anywhere within the well when we next
measure it well I hope this video blew
your minds just like it does to me every
time I revisit this problem what we have
seen is that quantum particles behave in
very different ways to classical
particles and this really provides
almost infinite possibilities for
quantum theory you can check many of
those in my other videos if you liked
this video or if you like to send me
suggestions for future videos please
subscribe